i'm here i'm so excited to be here
you're here all week ross i am here all
week girl i'm not leaving
oh good i don't want you to i'm so
excited
thank you and lots to talk about lots
going on in the world by the way it was
hard
like i we had to edit stories out
there's just so much going on all right
well first up
we have got to wish the dodgers and the
rays best of luck tonight because
it's time for sports for sports
okay can i actually do the whistle live
next time i think if we're going to talk
sports someone should give me a whistle
i you know what that's happening
tomorrow
perfect check checkity check okay it's
game six and the dodgers lead three to
two if they win
it'll be their first title since 1988
and if the rays win
well we've got an even more exciting
baseball game at higher stakes tomorrow
night so good luck to la
and good luck tampa bay hey that rhymes
ross big sports fans well
okay i like football i watch the
seahawks so i pay attention the world
series when the uh when the was it the
dodger um
you see understand right i don't really
i hope people who want to score a goal
score a goal tonight whatever however it
works good for them
you know what i do watch though is a
league of their own like
537 times a year it's the best movie
ever i
just rewatched it the other day you want
to have your mind blown before i came
out rosie o'donnell texted me that she's
watching right now
no yes i swear to god she's amazing
yeah oh my god and she was like best
friends with madonna
all the way may um you know her name
i love it well speaking of fun feminine
stories
this one really spoke to me um people
reports that jenna bush hager shared an
amazing story and back when the obamas
first moved into the white house she and
her sister barbara
gave sasha and malia the grand tour they
showed them their new bedrooms and what
jenna remembers most is teaching the
girls to slide down the banister in the
solarium
and it was the bush sisters favorite
thing to do
and now the obama sisters were there and
happy to take over i mean ross
come on isn't this the best visual ever
four first girls sliding down a banister
a grand banister on a loop forever yeah
it's the way that it should be
right this transfer of power and i just
think maybe we should make a rule
that from now on after every election
the the former first family and the new
first family get together and they do
like a movie night
mani pedis facials i mean i just
love this story it's so sweet and it
just
these four girls at their you know
tender young ages being like so
cute and sliding down banisters it's so
wholesome i can't even handle it i had
to talk about that
it's really adorable i know okay you
know what's another thing that makes me
really happy
the smell of chicken and jack in the box
agrees apparently
because the washington post reports that
the chain is giving away
chicken scented masks for free they
protect you from coved and make you
hungry all day long
and look we've got some here are you
gonna try it are you
too chicken
why did the chicken cross the road ross
to get to jack-in-the-box
that's right that's right hold on does
it really smell oh my god
it really
like if you've got a dog in the house
that is hardcore
chicken smell okay i wonder if the
scientists really like studied this or
if they just
winged it and
i'm telling you it really smells like
chicken
and like fries it's got that pavlovian
like
yeah here we go yeah we're gonna have
this it's giving me in the most
comforting way ever
like food courts don't you miss a mall
yes yeah like are we going like to the
walk
place or this place
all right well can i keep can i keep
this absolutely
into it i think jack in the box because
they sent these to us thank you jack in
the box thank you
um and i'm a west coast gal so um ross i
think you have a little entertainment
news for us oh yeah hey hit me it's time
for entertainment news
cultured okay uh cnn business reports
mattel
has launched a limited edition elton
john style barbie the day has finally
come
all right eldon john has his barbie and
you know how hard it
is to get your hands on these you can't
do it you can't find one guess what
yeah mattel sent us one i know i was
setting it up
by the way i have to say she is kicking
hot
can i tell you this is the ultimate gay
goal to have your own barbie
and uh now all i want is a ross matthews
barbie and mine would be in a caftan
playing bingo in palm springs what would
you if you i know you had a bar beef
with charlie's angels
i did and then my daughter opened the
box and i had been saving it but then i
was like oh my god i so don't want to be
that jerk who's like um
that's my barbie and we gotta keep it in
the box i was like you know what play
with it that's perfect
but you know who i really think that she
would bond with
oh god oh courtney
all right it's from the 80s american
girl doll
courtney oh i think you two are going to
have some wild times
trust me the 80s are like the funnest
okay ready hold on
hey courtney what's up
oh my god alton hey
let's partay love the skirt
oh my god you know i feel like courtney
might need to go to the american girl
salon and she might need american girl
brush yeah
she well speaking of oh wait you have
more news
yeah i do because speaking of icons
people are and this is the story of the
day we have to talk about people are
up in arms about drake i love drake oh i
got it we had
his 34th birthday recently and on the
menu we got a sneak peek and the menu is
extensive but there was one item we have
to discuss
he served mac and cheese drew now are
you a fan of mac and cheese
it's um my favorite food on planet earth
uh
okay well then you're gonna care as much
as i call mac and cheese a gateway carb
for me so i try not to eat it but
drake added a little bit to it uh in the
menu there was tomatoes
capers parsley and are you ready for
this the most controversial issue of
2020
in his mac and cheese
drake it's no good um
i mean drake is the hottest coolest most
exciting
perfect amazing cool killer guy
ever but raises
i know i'm gonna tell you this you know
what's perfect about mac and cheese
everything mac and cheese right drake
don't worry our forefathers figured it
out
you don't have to add anything to it
it's perfect as is mac and cheese
if you're going to use your noodle use
it on something other than mac and
cheese love them
right we love you
and we're sorry we don't love raisins
and mac and cheese but we love you and
i'm going to eat this all through the
[Music]
commercial